[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue pour une
nouvelle semaine d'information locale
sur tv et 78 nous sommes le lundi 5 mars
tout de suite les titres de ce set 8
journal 32 équipes en lice pour
concevoir le meilleur prototype la
rencontre régionale des trophées de
robotique se tenait samedi dernier à
montigny le bretonneux et des matches
entre robots autour de défis à relever
est notamment alimenté une ville en eau
potable quatre groupes de jeunes disent
yvelines ont participé à l'événement ce
jeudi 8 mars c'est la journée
internationale des droits des femmes à
cette occasion plusieurs villes de saint
quentin en yvelines se mobilisent à
manier un mot une semaine femmes du
monde se déroule jusqu'à dimanche et à
guyancourt
le temps des femmes se tient en ce
moment pour en parler en plateau
bénédicte allié à corinne adjointe au
maire adjointe au maire donc en charge
de la culture et du patrimoine
et puis c'est en ce moment le début du
printemps des poètes une vingtième
édition qui se tient jusqu'au 18 mars
une vingtaine de dates placée sous le
signe des ardeurs le rendez-vous a été
lancée samedi pendant le marché de mort
par un reportage à suivre
invité de ce journal également l'école 3
i/s à elancourt 60 de ces étudiants
étaient vendredi à la 43e cérémonie des
césars pour réaliser des interviews des
lauréats on en parle tout à l'heure dans
le journal avant de développer ses
titres elle a rouvert au public samedi
dernier la communauté emmaüs a repris
ses activités à trappes après un an et
demi d'arrêt elle locaux qui n'étaient
plus adaptés ont eu le droit à un
rafraîchissement et des travaux pour
rendre les lieux plus fonctionnel avec
notamment un espace de vente que vous
voyez sur ces images
emmaüs récupère vos objets les remet en
état si nécessaire et les revend à des
prix bas cinq compagnons font partie de
la communauté explications au micro de
nicolas landry
la première des choses à emmaüs et qu'on
lutte contre toutes les cause
d'inégalité et d'exclusion voilà une
manière générale quand on accueille
aussi les personnes sans abri en rupture
avec notre société et que ces personnes
qu'on appelle compagnons d'emmaüs
retrouve ici une dignité grâce à un
travail qui leur est fournie
c'est ça qui est important et ce travail
se fait à partir d'objets de seconde
main que les gens viennent nous donner
ces objets sont retravaillées revalorisé
pour ensuite être revendues c'est ce qui
fait fonctionner l'ensemble de la
structure sans subvention tout peut être
donnée à emmaüs à condition que les
objets soient en bon état la réception
des dons se fait du mardi au samedi
l'espace de vente est lui ouvert les
mercredis et samedis plus d'informations
sur le site le site d'emmaüs trappe qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran
je vous le disais dans les titres ce
week end à montigny le bretonneux se
tenait la rencontre ile-de-france des
trophées de robotique troisième fois
consécutive qu'elle se tenait à la ferme
du manet 34 équipes de la région se sont
affrontés dans des matchs avec leurs
robots objectif la qualification pour la
finale nationale reportage de nicolas
landry ils ont conservé leur titre
acquis en 2017 les destroy heures du
collège louis armand de
savigny-le-temple en seine et marne ont
remporté les finales ile-de-france des
trophées de robotique
une victoire acquise au milieu de la
ville du futur les robots doivent réunir
des cubes de construction écologique
libéré l'eau potable amener l'eau usée
dans la station d'épuration différentes
tâches qui rapporte des points c'est
innover avec l'équipe chercher des
solutions pour
et les tâches qui nous sont demandés
10 et les fabriquer tout le procédé pour
faire le robot élaborer une stratégie
pour 34 équipes d'île de france des
jeunes âgés de 7 à 18 ans des maisons de
quartier des établissements scolaires
participent à ce projet pédagogique ils
ont eu six mois pour construire un robot
à partir d'un cahier des charges
alors c'est intéressant pour ces jeunes
parce que il et ils se servent de leurs
mains
il mène un projet de a à z puisqu'en
septembre il n'avait rien et maintenant
l'exemple des robots totalement
fonctionnel et ça leur permet aussi de 2
travailler en équipe une autre équipe à
conserver son titre les montini ecocity
ont remporté le prix éco citoyenneté
pour leurs maquettes sur la ville
écologique une installation composée
d'une serre d'une voiture électrique et
de deux éoliennes à lévis mme fricker
traitance écologique avec moins
d'émissions de co2 ça se développe de
plus en plus d'aimer l'économie et les
voitures aussi sans production
on voit de plus en plus de voitures
hybrides électriques
des supers engagé le projet leur a parlé
très très rapidement on est très
rapidement en partie sur un projet un
peu style écolo parce que c'est ce qui
nous a c'est ce qui est ressorti un
petit peu des cahiers des charges et on
a tous pris ensemble l'idée de
de faire une maquette son pouvoir
habiller nos cendres la finale nationale
des trophées de robotique aura lieu le 7
et 8 avril prochains à saint quentin
dans le département de l'aisne politique
le député modem de la 2e circonscription
des yvelines jean noël barrot conviait
la presse ce lundi matin points
d'actualité assure psa permanence à
versailles il a été question du logement
l'élu demande plus de souplesse pour la
loi sru qui contraint les communes à
disposer de 25 % de logements sociaux
est d'ici 2025 le parlementaire a
également exprimé ses regrets quant aux
dernières annonces sur la ligne 18 une
arrivée retardée à 2027 sur le plateau
de saclay et la liaison avec versailles
en 2030 propos recueillis par wilfrid
richy et patrick jacques de dixmude
on aurait voulu que le calendrier
accéléré pour les jo soient tenus
mais à la fois on est on est soulagés de
voir que la la promesse reste tenue
c'est à dire qu'on revient sur le
calendrier initial avec une arrivée à
versailles en 2030
il faudrait bien vigilant que cela soit
soit bien le cas
le souci est l'attention doit être
portée à la période intermédiaire la
période transitoire pendant laquelle il
faut que nous puissions apporter des
solutions notamment grâce aux transports
en site propre
puis grâce à peut-être d'autres modes de
transport qui viendront en complément
résoudre les problèmes de circulation
sur 7 sur cet axe rappelez-vous les
inondations ont frappé les yvelines en
ce début d'année et après le début de la
décrue l'heure est au nettoyage la scène
a laissé derrière elle de nombreux
déchets et bactéries dangereuses pour la
santé l'assainissement peut s'avérer
dangereux une société spécialisée créée
par d'anciens pompiers et policiers
investi en ce moment en ile de france
elle intervient en ce moment en
ile-de-france comme à villennes sur
seine dans les yvelines un sujet de
margaux du long pour vyas grand paris
pour accéder à ces habitations isolées
du monde il faut traverser la seine en
bateau sur cette île une centaine de
pavillons étaient touchées par la crue
il ya deux semaines baptiste dirar des
dirigeants de la société intervient avec
son équipe dans ce chalet au 15 cm d'eau
s'étaient infiltrés mccaw visage
combinaison étanche dans cette maison
ces missions des contaminations ont
retiré leurs vêtements au sol et ensuite
le revêtement qui a soul sous le sol qui
est un usb et là un parfait qui est
massif qui collait reason en fait tout
un tas de facteurs et d'éléments et
d'agents pathogènes qui conte
indésirables pour la santé
la scène en se retirant a laissé de
nombreuses bactéries nocives pour la
santé pouvant provoquer des diarrhées
des nausées et de violence passe une
fois le seul retirer un puissant produit
est appliqué pour tous et toutes traces
de bactéries
c'est une surface qui est habitable dans
un environnement qui est habitable
eh bien nous allons avec une deuxième
méthodologie
appliquez un bactéricide et un virucide
de manière à rendre les lieux
complètement sainte sabine a fait appel
à cette entreprise spécialisée dans le
nettoyage après sinistre
elle ne regrette pas la venue de ces
professionnels je n'aurais pas pu le
faire j'aurais pas pu faire tout tout
seul quoi travaillant et en une gamine à
mon équipe et j'aurais pas pu
physiquement et moralement j'aurais pas
depuis tout gérer tout seul donc je suis
bien contente qu'ils soient là il me
détruit ma maison c'est pas grave
au total la crue y aura coûté environ
12000 euros
l'intégralité devrait être prise en
charge par l'assurance sabine sera de
retour chez elle d'ici un mois
ce jeudi 8 mars est la journée
internationale des droits des femmes un
moment de sensibilisation sur l'égalité
femmes-hommes c'est aussi l'occasion de
commémorer à les luttes des femmes
d'hier et d'aujourd'hui à travers le
monde à saint quentin en yvelines
plusieurs communes se mobilisent pour le
rendez vous c'est le cas à guyancourt
pour en parler avec points à une invitée
n'a rejoint un plateau c'est bénédicte
alico in bonsoir bonsoir et merci pour
cette invitation merci à vous d'être
venu alors vous êtes adjointe au maire
de guyancourt en charge de la culture et
du patrimoine la ville de guyancourt qui
organise une grande partie du mois de
mars la 8e édition du temps des femmes
c'est jusqu'au 24 mars alors certaines
villes consacre une journée à
l'événement d'autres une semaine
pourquoi guyancourt on a décidé de
consacrer quasiment un mois à cet
événement en effet le droit des femmes
ce n'est pas une question de d'une
journée et
pour nous c'est important de mettre en
lumière pendant un bon mois mais c'est
un travail quotidien de tous les
services et ce temps des femmes à
guyancourt et surtout une transversalité
de tous les services en direction des
habitants ça c'est important de le
préciser parce que nombreux ateliers
sont en direction des habitants et puis
la diversité donc voilà bien sûr c'est
une vraie préoccupation quotidienne mais
pour en revenir sur notre temps des
femmes cette année
peut-être en rapport avec le sport notre
thématique et traoré mouvement s'est
encore et mouvement femmes corps mes
mouvements
en effet c'était important de
de décliner autour du corps de la santé
bien sûr du sport bien sûr mais aussi
réappropriation de son propre corps bien
sûr on peut parler aussi des violences
et du bien-être bien sûr pour
avoir une diversité dans tous les
secteurs
le but de cet événement aussi on re
précise les objectifs c'est de rappeler
encore une fois que l'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes c'est toujours un
enjeu de société fait tout à fait c'est
un enjeu de société
c'est notre rôle d'élu aussi d'en parler
d'entendre ce qui se passe est en effet
d'avoir des actions aussi en direction
de tous les habitants c'est ce qu'on
fait mais aussi faut pas oublier la
jeunesse et avoir une
peut-être un apprentissage de certaines
notions de vivre ensemble aujourd'hui
justement l'événement a démarré samedi
dernier avec un spectacle s'appelle la
rage des petites sirènes un spectacle de
marionnettes qui étaient proposés aux
enfants dès 6 ans là on le voit à
sensibiliser les jeunes voilà dès le
plus jeune âge en faire des adultes
responsables et bien sûr aussi les en
direction des parents parce que l'idée
c'est aussi de mobiliser les parents
donc l'école des parents est très
partenaires dans ce moment là aussi mais
je pense aussi à la jeunesse parce qu'il
va y avoir beaucoup de
réappropriation sur le corps expliqué
que le corps et la culte du corps donc
il y aura une belle conférence toujours
en relation avec le service jeunesse et
bien sûr parler aussi de ce qui se passe
dans la programmation culturelle faire
venir les coquettes c'est d'aller à bel
ébat ont fait venir les que ça c'est un
spectacle du monde on peut il peut faire
de l'humour sur un sujet important
d'élus tome tout à fait et puis faire
connaître aussi que dans la culture je
pense à la batterie de faire venir des
femmes qui jouent des femmes célèbres de
tous pays déjà voilà donc la version la
buse à queue de la danse du sport
également ses actifs et variées voilà
c'est varié et l'objectif c'est vraiment
de faire discuter les gens d'échanger de
vivre ensemble c'est la base de notre
direction en direction des habitants
donc c'est la base de notre société quoi
voilà j'imagine c'est difficile de
choisir la d'ici le 24 mars les deux
trois grands temps forts on va dire à
suivre portez vous bien les filles même
si c'est avec les filles c'est ouvert à
tous
ça c'est important qu'on dise que nos
temps des femmes c'est vraiment de les
changes
bien sûr la thématique c'est la femme
mais c'est ouvert aux hommes aussi et
donc sportez vous bien les filtres ça
permet de découvrir des tas d'activités
sportives
ça c'est le dimanche 11 d'accord je
reviens aussi sur l'école des parents
parce qu'il ya des belles thématique
cette année
et puis et donc avec une thématique sur
la jeunesse bien sûr tous les ateliers
qui ont lieu dans les maisons de
quartier
nos services culturels puisque je suis à
la culture voilà c'est vraiment une
problématique qui est intéressante toute
l'année et voilà je pense que c'est
important dans lé contexte actuel de
s'amender important pour l'année en
cours toujours toujours ces quotidiens
et c'est important d'avoir cette parité
on l'a déjà à la culture puisque les bas
nous fait déjà une programmation en
parité
la parité est importante aussi sur les
services
municipaux parce que à guyancourt on a
des directeurs et
dix sur dix est ainsi que des chefs de
service cinquante-cinq enfants donc
c'est intéressant de savoir que ben il
faut le vivre
voilà et toute cette programmation du
temps des femmes on peut bien sûr la
retrouver sur le site internet de
guyancourt qui s'affiche en bas de
l'écran merci bénédicte alico in d'avoir
été avec nous adjointe au maire va de
guyancourt en charge de la culture et du
patrimoine à magny les hameaux aussi on
se mobilise pour défendre les droits des
femmes une semaine spéciale femmes du
monde vient de débuter est aujourd'hui
un concours cuisine a vu s'opposer dans
la bonne humeur femmes et hommes alors
qu'ils s'en sort le mieux la réponse
avec ce reportage denis nicolas
kirillovitch il faut au menu du jour un
feuilleté de saumon sur son lit de
fondue de poireaux la recette est
appétissante et les chefs à l'écouté des
conseils
l'enjeu est de taille qui des hommes ou
des femmes seront les meilleurs
cuisiniers
si le concours est sérieux la bonne
humeur est de mise pour cette activité
initiée par le centre social de
magny-les-hameaux objectif principal
cuire les idées reçues on est capable de
faire tous la même chose
le problème c'est que la société nous a
mis dans des cars et qu'effectivement
les hommes font très rarement la cuisine
par contre il bricole peut-être un peu
mieux que les femmes mais ça change il
ya des ateliers bricolage pour les
femmes
les ateliers cuisine pour les hommes on
est en train de régler entrée plat et
dessert deux équipes de cinq personnes
se sont affrontées le temps d'une
matinée à l'heure du repas un jury avait
la lourde tâche de départager femmes et
hommes de la soupe au potiron l'un se
trouvait super
l'idée de mélanger avec de laniscat me
semble très bien il ya un peu trop de
c'est un peu trop relevé je pense pour
moi mais sinon ateliers culinaires
débats expositions la semaine dédiée aux
femmes du monde prévoit une série
d'animations jusqu'au 11 mars
toute cette semaine est fait pour la
convivialité le vivre ensemble et le
fait de se sentir bien les uns avec les
autres pour l'histoire ce sont les
femmes qui ont remporté le concours de
cuisine c'était l'évènement sportif du
week end dans les yvelines la 76e
édition du paris-nice a été lancée hier
dimanche depuis l'île des
impressionnistes de chatou les
supporters ont répondu présent pour
encourager les 154 coureurs malgré des
conditions climatiques est difficile
michael et me doro et nicolas dandois ni
le froid ni le vent ni la pluie ont
découragé les aficionados du paris nice
is it et plus d'une centaine de
supporters à avoir fait le déplacement
pour approcher les 154 cours sur l'île
des impressionnistes de chatou pour le
départ de cette 76e édition
les voie rentrer voir le d'organisation
de sa tour
fais beaucoup de vélo c'est un peu la
fête du vélo moi je fais du vélo pour le
plaisir donc puis c'est l'occasion pour
les enfants aussi de devoir tout
l'équipement puis c'est un peu la fête
c'est sympa même si c'est vrai que les
conditions météo sont pas sympas même
enthousiasme du public qui ne décline
pas depuis la signature de la convention
yvelines paris nice en 2010 ce succès ne
surprend pas l'organisation
c'est un département qui est juste à
côté de paris paris est là et en même
temps c'est la forêt c'est la campagne
bat qui a tout pour pouvoir faire du
vélo le vélo des champions comme la
bicyclette en famille tranquillement
avec les animaux sur le vélo cette année
le chouchou c'est lui julian alaphilippe
pour son troisième paris nice le coureur
français de 25 ans a pu voir sa cote de
popularité grandir auprès du grand
public
si vous
allez je dire bonne chance ça fait
plaisir ouais on est prêt pour la
première étape on va donner le maximum
c'est à croire qu'on aime on aime la
façon dont tu couvres son panache ça ça
passe sans voir la course
ouais qu'il ait toujours au bout de
lui-même qu'il essaye toujours d'attaqué
de gagner de quoi lasser un coin qui va
gagner des grandes courses à d'année
c'est sûr julian alaphilippe pourra
continuer à conquérir le coeur du public
qui vit noie dans les prochaines années
le partenariat entre les organisateurs
du paris nice et les yvelines s'étend
jusqu'en 2021 la consécration pour deux
films 120 battements par minute de robin
campillo sacré à six reprises le film au
revoir là-haut d'albert dupontel qui en
récolte lui cinq récompenses la 43e
cérémonie des césar se tenait vendredi
dernier à la salle pleyel à paris la
crème du cinéma français étaient bien
sûr présentes mais aussi des étudiants
de l'école troisième l'institut de
l'image et du son
implantée notamment à elancourt pour en
parler avec moi en plateau trois invités
stéphane lamy bonsoir soir vous êtes le
directeur pédagogique adjoint de
troisième
vous êtes venu avec deux de vos
étudiants ton à manon dubois bonsoir et
emilie fortin bonsoir donc vous avez
participé
donc ce vendredi à cette cérémonie des
césar va démarrer l'entretien avec vous
comment comment vous avez vécu ce moment
maintenant peut-être pour commencer bah
c'était vraiment vraiment très très
sympa
c'est quand même étonnant de pouvoir
faire ça il n'y a pas beaucoup d'écoles
qui ont des partenariats comme ça donc
oui non c'était c'était vraiment
agréable mais les bulls et vécu comment
cette cérémonie
c'était une chance de pouvoir accéder à
et puis c'est formateur aussi on arrive
quand même sur une cérémonie qui est
assez connue donc c'est qu'un agréable
de pouvoir travailler dessus quoi est-ce
que c'était un rêve pour tous les deux
vous qui a été étudiant dans cette école
d'audiovisuel d'image de son voilà de
faire une cérémonie aussi renommé qui
est celle des césar c'est est un rêve un
banc tout cas pour moi oui parce que
j'ai toujours suivi les césar à la télé
avec ma famille et me dire ah ben là tu
travailles pour eux c'était annoncé
c'était très très sympa alors stéphane
lamy c'était un partenariat
institutionnel qui est mise en place
depuis 2009 avec l'académie des césars
vous envoyer chaque année des étudiants
sur l'événement comment ce partenariat
est il rendu possible alors au départ on
a depuis huit ans on accueillait au
départ simplement des master class
donc avec des lauréats d'accord et puis
petit à petit on est monté en puissance
de manière à couvrir en fait l'ensemble
des événements qui lit avant la
cérémonie parce qu'on connaît surtout la
cérémonie en elle-même donc du vendredi
soir il ya tant d aller voter aussi tous
les à côtés il ya la soirée des
producteurs la remise des prix césar et
techniques l'annoncent des nominés les
soirées des révélations donc tout un
type d'événement en un peu plus d'une
dizaine d'événements
mais le point d'orgue bien sûr c'est la
cérémonie donc nous nous réalisons tous
les ans en fait les vidéos pour
l'académie que l'ont d'ailleurs on peut
voir directement sur leur site
d'accord ce qui permet aux étudiants
justement de travailler en situation
mais tout en étant encadrés avec des
avec des des permanents des gens de des
intervenants de l'école pour près de
lâcher justement comme ça dans l'inconnu
au départ kouame est la preuve que oui
ce partenariat renouvelé chaque année
c'est ça montre que les les étudiants
travaillent bien chaque année sur sur
ces éléments
ah bah oui ça sinon le font depuis
longtemps parce que effectivement là on
est là la mise en situation à l'est les
directs aller direct ils sont face à
aussi à des professionnels donc il faut
avoir une attitude irréprochable
au delà des compétences techniques il
faut aussi avoir vraiment une attitude
irréprochable
derrière l'autre exemple le partenariat
institutionnel c'est au coeur de la
pédagogie de 2,3 y y est c'est c'est
important que ces étudiants soient tout
de suite en pratique qui mettent en
pratique les les savoirs qui qui le
peuvent
voilà qui peuvent acquérir à l'institut
et c'est exactement ça on est on est on
est connu pour justement dénoue mise en
situation complète à travers les
différentes émissions de télévision les
films que l'on peut réaliser à l'école
mais ça ne remplace pas pour un étudiant
le fait de sortir de l'école et
d'apprendre à travailler véritablement
en situation donc c'est vrai qu'on est
on des très friands de tout ce type de
partenariat mais manon ml je reviens
vers vous racontez nous racontez-nous
chacune comment votre soirée de vendredi
s'est déroulée la milice et va du coup
en fait on avait
et un travail chacune d'accord en fait
on était sur le plateau
c'est un plateau
c'est un plateau invités enfin un
plateau lauréats c'est à dire que dès
que les nommer
on enfin leurs prix donc les lorrains
viennent sur le plateau télé et viennent
donc faire une interview et donc nous on
a deux jobs on a le premier job que
manon à fès et hop et magnéto d'accord
qui lance le direct et moi après j'étais
là pour pour mettre un générique de
début de fin et de nettoyer un peu tôt
et on mettait directement en fait la
vidéo sur facebook sur la page des
césars mets pas trop de pression avant
la cérémonie manon comment alex et
préparer justement cette cérémonie des
césar alors déjà en fait quand même une
répétition avant pour se comprendre
entre le réalisateur et les deux
monteuse et même avec les sont dits
également il y avait deux sondes y ait
de 3e et ensuite c'est parti quoi on dès
qu'on entend qui a gagné le césar donc
par exemple meilleur son et bien là haut
up on se prépare tout va très vite après
c'est ça c'est le boulot rires
s'enchaînent et du coup l'allumage et le
travail n'est pas terminé il ya eu cette
cérémonie là ça va se poursuivre tête du
montage des voilà de démontage à faire
pendant ces deux semaines encore et
pendant les prochaines semaines oui oui
là en fait
on va avoir la sur deux semaines on doit
faire le making of des césar c'est à
dire qu'on
on a tous des vidéos de la préparation
des césar le tapis rouge
et c'est extra et en fait on va faire un
long making of qui doit durer dix quinze
vingt minutes ça dépend mais on
travaille
du coup tout tout othily avantage
travail sur ce making of
c'était une amie là les prochains
événements pour les étudiants de 3e sur
ses partenariats institutionnels
alors là on est plutôt au fun
partenariat parce qu'on vient de
terminer donc voilà partis césar si
c'était les dernières étapes donc dont
éliminé manon parlait on vient de faire
les cérémonies d on a fait les trophées
du film français et saudi des lumières
on a fait les lauriers aussi
l'audiovisuel là pour nous les grands
événements ce sont les courts métrages
en fait là que les étudiants sont partis
ce week-end donc on n'attaque en fait
les la deuxième partie du jeu on va dire
de l'année scolaire qui correspond pour
nous à la mise en production
donc dans les différentes années dans
les différentes filières et des journées
portes ouvertes les rôles ce week-end le
week-end prochain absolument samedi
voilà dès 10 heures journée portes
ouvertes et vous pouvez retrouver bien
sûr un toutes les informations sur le
site internet de troisième
merci à vous trois d'avoir été avec nous
manon dubois emilie fortin étudiante à
a3 yes et merci à stéphane amis est
directeur pédagogique adjoint de l'école
pour plus d'informations je rappelle le
site internet de 3 i/s pour refermer ce
journal samedi dernier c'était le coup
d'envoi du printemps des poètes à saint
quentin en yvelines le lancement de ce
rendez vous annuel a eu lieu en plein
coeur du marché de maurepas une
vingtième édition placée sous le signe
des ardeurs relire et aurélie rond et
nicolas landry des poèmes déclamés entre
les fruits et les fleurs une scène
quelque peu insolite pour lancer le
printemps des poètes thème retenu cette
année ardeurs au pluriel
un thème que la poétesse québécoise
nicole brossard connaît bien
allons
du côté des sanglots plonger notre
ardeur dans les questions il s organiser
les ardeurs s'il en faut toujours
surtout lorsqu'on est en poésie c'est la
motivation c'est la passion c'est la
figure ans je sais que des poètes
écrivent dans le grand calme dans
l'anxiété moi je pense que j'écris plus
tôt je suis plutôt du côté de l'ardeur
tout naturellement c'est donc sous le
signe de toutes les ardeurs que se
déroulera cette 20e édition
coordonné par les itinéraires poétique
le lieu choisi pour le lancement de la
manifestation n'était pas anodin le
thème ardeurs est un thème très général
on va dire très générique c'est à dire
qu'on peut y mettre ce qu'on veut de
dans un vous pouvez parler de l'ardeur
l'ardeur au travail ces gens qui sont là
pendant des journées entières sur des
marchés ils ont intérêt à avoir une
sacrée ardeurs intérieure et une envie
de voilà deux de faire quelque chose de
leur vie pour venir sur ce marché une
quinzaine de comédiens est intervenu sur
l'ensemble du marché pour dire des
textes et distribuer des cartes postales
sur lesquels avaient été imprimées des
poèmes je trouve que de faire sortir la
poésie eu envie pour tout le monde c'est
super voilà tout le monde peut en
profiter et découvrir un petit peu que
la poésie c'est toute la vie et tous les
jours et a toujours eu des choses et
jusqu'au 18 mars une vingtaine de
rendez-vous vous attendent sur le
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
et dans le cadre de cette 20e édition du
printemps des poètes c'est la fin de ce
journal merci de l'avoir suivi un replay
a consultés sur notre site internet et
notre application mobile tv 78 belle
soirée est excellent de semaine à tous
[Musique]